Transcriptor: Sara Rodriguez Santos
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Hoy me gustaría hablarles de ciencia.
Pero no de lo que la ciencia dice,
si no de aquello
que los científicos aún no sabemos decir.
O mejor dicho,
de aquello que aún no podemos
o quizás no queremos ver:
de nuestro punto ciego.
La neurociencia tiene
un conflicto de intereses
y, la mayor parte del tiempo,
aún sin declarar.
Un sujeto, el científico,
estudia a otro sujeto,
un humano, un gusano, una mosca, un ratón.
Pero hace ver que su sujeto de estudio
es un objeto
y que el propio científico
no está presente.
Fíjense en el truco:
empezamos con dos sujetos
y casi sin darnos cuenta,
por arte de magia,
acabamos con un objeto.
Este conflicto de intereses
tiene una doble problemática:
En primer lugar está
el problema del observador,
el sujeto que experimenta.
En segundo lugar,
el problema de lo observado,
el sujeto sobre el que se experimenta.
Bien, el problema del observador
nos lleva al de la objetividad:
si es posible pronunciarse
sobre la realidad
como algo que está ahí fuera,
independiente de quien la observa.
Pero no vemos el mundo como es,
vemos el mundo como somos.
Los físicos, hace ahora justo un siglo,
se toparon de frente con este problema
y descubrieron que la pura objetividad
es un mito:
el observador no se puede dejar
fuera de la ecuación.
Las demás ciencias han resistido
a esta revolución conceptual
casi sin modificar ni un ápice
de su abordaje,
que por otro lado sigue anclado
en la física del siglo XVII.
Ignorar al observador no es algo
que podamos hacer o seguir haciendo
demasiado tiempo.
Ponerse una capa o una bata blanca
no es ser objetivo,
no es desaparecer de la escena.
La objetividad es algo que
se construye entre sujetos.
Y esto nos lleva al segundo problema:
el problema de lo observado.
Este concierne especialmente
a las ciencias de la vida y de la mente,
incluidas la neurociencia
y la psicología, entre otras.
Y aquí nos encontramos con
la siguiente paradoja:
la biología estudia la vida casi
como si estuviera muerta
y la neurociencia estudia la mente
como si fuera un producto anecdótico
de la materia cerebral.
Pero yo me pregunto, y les pregunto:
¿Se puede estudiar la vida matándola?
¿Se puede estudiar la mente
desmontándola? ¿Podemos entenderlas?
El amor no se puede reducir
a un escáner cerebral
y no encontrarán la humedad del agua
entre sus moléculas.
La ciencia es parte de la vida,
no al revés.
Este hábito, que es casi un vicio,
de pensar lo superior
en términos de lo inferior
lo hemos heredado
de la biología molecular
del siglo pasado,
esa que afirma que
la vida no es más que bioquímica
y que, por ende, la mente no puede ser
más que electroquímica.
Pero cada vez que oigan a alguien decir
que A no es nada más que B, desconfíen.
No nos metamos por ahí ahora.
Volvamos al punto inicial,
a la idea que quiero traerles hoy aquí
para que la cuestionemos:
que tratamos a los sujetos como objetos.
Aquí podemos echar mano de
una idea maravillosa, a mí me encanta:
es la idea de "Umwelt",
que en alemán significa "mundo",
pero no cualquier mundo,
un mundo general... no, no.
Es algo así como el mundo dotado
de significado para el sujeto
que lo experimenta:
el ambiente lleno de significado.
Pongamos un ejemplo:
un árbol es un árbol,
pero un árbol para una hormiga
tiene muy poco que ver con
un árbol para un carpintero.
Para la hormiga es un refugio,
para el carpintero probablemente
una oportunidad para hacer una mesa.
Cada uno tiene su "Umwelt", su mundo.
Hay tantos mundos como organismos vivos,
pues cada uno tiene su particular
formar de mirar al mundo.
Y esto nos lleva
al siguiente descubrimiento:
todos los organismos comparten el mundo,
pero no todos los organismos
tienen el mismo mundo en común.
Así, cuando estudiamos en el laboratorio
el comportamiento de un ratón
lo ponemos en una cajita
de un metro cuadrado,
lo medimos muy bien durante cinco minutos,
es muy probable que nuestro esfuerzo
por ser objetivos
acabe siendo, en el fondo, una proyección
de nuestro mundo sobre el del ratón
y caigamos en una forma sutil
de antropomorfismo.
Hay un choque de mundos
en nuestros laboratorios.
Llegamos, pues, al punto ciego
de la neurociencia,
que es el de la percepción.
Como dijo Morfeo en Matrix:
"el destino no está carente
de cierta ironía",
pues parece que precisamente lo que
la ciencia no consigue percibir
es la percepción misma.
Para abordar este problema,
pues no vengo a traerles hoy una solución,
no la tenemos,
permítanme que comparta con Uds.
nuestros esfuerzos.
Y lo hemos hecho con unos elementos
un tanto inesperados,
combinando magia
con inteligencia artificial.
Ambos son unos espejos muy poderosos
para estudiar la percepción
y la cognición humana, como verán.
Y al mismo tiempo representan un híbrido
entre lo nuevo y lo viejo,
pues la magia es un arte milenario
y la inteligencia artificial una técnica
relativamente reciente.
Bien, empecemos por la magia:
la magia es el arte
de producir en el espectador
la experiencia de lo imposible.
Fíjense: una cosa es no saber
cómo algo sucede,
y esto nos pasa mucho a los científicos,
pero otra distinta es creer
que aquello que ha sucedido no puede ser.
Para el espectador,
la ilusión es lo más real que hay
pues lo está percibiendo
en primera persona
y de manera concreta.
Aquí tienen un ejemplo:
estos dos iconos en gris tienen
exactamente el mismo tono de gris,
pero Uds. no lo perciben así, ¿verdad?
Es por el gradiente que está de contexto
que parecen dos grises distintos.
¿De quién fiarse pues?
Como dijo Goethe, y lo dijo muy en serio:
"la ilusión visual es la realidad visual".
Además, no hay magia sin espectador.
El sujeto es el núcleo principal
del fenómeno mágico.
Bien, pues con Miguel Ángel Gea,
un mago profesional
que, por cierto, tiene su teatro
muy cerca de aquí, el Teatro Encantado,
diseñamos una serie de trucos
muy sencillos,
maniobras muy simplificadas
pero efectivas,
basándonos en su dominio
de la magia con monedas.
Hacerlas aparecer, desaparecer,
cambiar de lugar, etc.
En primer lugar, queríamos medir
con mucha precisión
el movimiento de sus manos
en el juego de manos
para estudiar su destreza
y cómo su destreza nos consigue engañar.
Y para ello utilizamos un algoritmo
de visión por ordenador
basado en inteligencia artificial.
Para explicarlo muy brevemente:
un humano le enseña a la máquina,
dada una imagen, un punto de interés,
por ejemplo, el dedo índice o una moneda.
Clica en la imagen y le dice:
"esto, máquina, para mí es el dedo".
Tras unos pocos ejemplos,
y esta es la gracia,
hay que entrenar solo con pocos ejemplos,
la máquina extrae propiedades
de los píxeles de la imagen
y, en principio, en futuras imágenes,
sabe ver dónde estará el dedo o la moneda.
Aquí les muestro
algunos de los resultados.
Bien, aquí Miguel Ángel está haciendo
algo que los magos no quieren hacer,
que es repetir el truco seguidamente,
muchas veces.
Pero bueno, nos lo permitió.
A continuación, nuestra idea
fue enseñarle a la máquina no solo
a ver la moneda cuando está visible,
sino a proponernos dónde cree
que está cuando no está visible.
Para eso, recuerden,
quien la entrena es el humano
así que tuvo el humano también
que proyectar su percepción
y decir "yo creo que está aquí",
"yo creo que está allí".
Y la máquina aprendió eso.
Como prueba de que esto funcionó,
les muestro el siguiente vídeo.
El punto que ven es donde la máquina
nos dice dónde está la moneda
o dónde cree que está la moneda.
Bien, a continuación hicimos
unos cuantos trucos de magia,
hoy solo les voy a poder mostrar uno,
los demás los pueden encontrar online.
Primero les voy a enseñar
un truco de magia para que lo disfruten
y luego les voy a enseñar el mismo truco
con lo que vio la máquina.
No pestañeen.
La mano es más rápida que el ojo.
La magia no está hecha
para servirse enlatada,
así sin contexto, de sopetón,
con un vídeo de siete segundos,
pero me pregunto si Miguel Ángel
les ha engañado.
A continuación veremos el mismo vídeo y
dónde la máquina cree que está la moneda,
a ver si le podemos hacer un truco
a la máquina.
Bien, todo ha pasado demasiado rápido
y tiene que ser así,
pues la magia no puede dejar mucho tiempo
a la mente analítica
para que descubra cómo está sucediendo
lo que está sucediendo.
Y esto nos lleva a un punto
también muy interesante,
sobre todo en nuestro trabajo
con los magos.
Y es que no se trata tanto de que
el mago nos explique el truco,
para que luego los neurocientíficos
lo estudiemos
y le contemos al mago
cómo funciona el truco.
Ellos llevan haciéndolo cientos de años.
Es más interesante
ir en la otra dirección.
¿Cómo? Pues utilizando lo que saben
los magos para estudiar algo
que es realmente fascinante
y a veces da un poco de miedo,
y es que tanto en el laboratorio,
como en el teatro como fuera en la vida,
la mente nos engaña casi todo el tiempo.
Bien, pero me dirán:
¿Qué hay de la máquina?
¿Aprende o no aprende?
¿Se le puede hacer un truco o no?
Bueno, aquí hay que ser cautos
con la inteligencia artificial.
En primer lugar, las máquinas
propiamente dicho, no ven, detectan.
Y además no atienden,
porque no tienen libertad para mirar
a un lado de la imagen
o a otra parte de la imagen.
Además, yo sostengo
que las máquinas no piensan,
sino que calculan.
Esto nos daría para
una larga conversación.
Bien, el truco que le hacemos a la máquina
en realidad, o así lo interpreto yo,
nos lo hacemos a nosotros mismos
a partir de aquello que le hemos
sabido enseñar a la máquina
de nuestra propia cognición.
Es algo así como un divertido
y fascinante juego de espejos.
Fíjense: el científico le pide al mago
que le haga un truco al espectador,
que a su vez enseña a la máquina,
para que de nuevo ante el mago
refleje y amplifique algunos de nuestros
procesos perceptuales y cognitivos.
Un juego de espejos deformantes para
entendernos mejor a nosotros mismos.
La magia nos recuerda algo que quizá
ya sabíamos pero habíamos olvidado,
sobre todo cuando estamos
tan ocupados en nuestros laboratorios:
que la mente, como la vida,
es contingente, chapucera.
Se equivoca, improvisa, aprende,
deforma y se deforma.
Las piezas no encajan y, sin embargo,
la vida sigue adelante.
Estudiar la mente humana
desde la mente humana
es algo verdaderamente fascinante,
pues nos sumerge
en multitud de mundos paralelos
que a veces incluso se tocan.
Como neurocientífico en pleno siglo XXI,
me veo inmerso en el siguiente reto:
el de cultivar una mente científica
que no por ello deje de ser
una mente participativa.
Solo el tiempo dirá si es verdaderamente
posible aún una ciencia humanista.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)